discovered something about the markets
that has allowed me to trade only 60 to
90 minutes in the morning to
consistently find profitable trades
every day before going to my full-time
job this is something that I've been
teaching for a little while and it
hasn't just worked for me it's worked
for a ton of other people and it stopped
them from jumping from YouTube video to
YouTube video and ended their years of
potential struggle with trading they
finally found something that is
consistent and the whole idea is this is
something something that is repeatable
every day so you can show up to the
markets know exactly what you want to do
have a consistent plan to follow and
execute it when the strategy shows up
and then you can move on with your day I
actually made over $600 this morning
with this exact strategy I see every day
and I've actually made a new addition to
the strategy that increases the
potential for the amount of Trades you
can take every day which I will show
after we go over a basic overview of how
this strategy works and then we'll dive
into the exact trade I took this morning
I'll walk you through how I entered
where I put my stop loss how I managed
to trade and then once it's going for a
profit how I exit and get out maximizing
the potential profit I could make now I
only trade using candlesticks and
drawing tools no indicators and what
this does is it allows you to simplify
your trading but allows you to also use
this analysis on any time frame or any
chart that you want I specifically trade
the S&P 500 futures the NASDAQ futures
and oil Futures but if you want to trade
this on a larger time frame than I do or
just on a different Market you can
because reading the candlesticks applies
to any Market these patterns show up the
same because you're reading the raw
price movement asset you're looking at
and it tells you the correct story and
so for me over time what I've realized
this does it is just allows me to create
a simple ified picture of what's going
in the market I can easily see okay
where are the major support zones and
where are the major resistance zones and
then potential channels or trend lines
that asset is trading in and so all I do
is I look for reversals off of those key
areas because those are the simplest to
look for again trading is all about
finding something that's repeatable and
so let me show you what is so repeatable
about this Market that you can execute
consistently every day and that is at
about 30 minutes after the Market opens
it likes to consistently reverse here's
today if we just go quickly to yesterday
here's about 8:00 as well for me the
Market opens at 7:30 and then at 8:00 it
generally kind of moves has potential to
slow down and then it reverses and so
those are the trades I'm looking for
consistently and so going into today the
first thing that I always do is I
actually like to look at a larger time
frame chart than when I trade and look
for those key areas and so going into
this morning if I just kind of Zoom to
where the market opened is the Market
opens up right here and so what I'm
looking at is okay we have some pretty
clear trend lines that the Market's kind
of respecting it's kind of in this
condensing upwards Channel and so
overnight the market kind of started to
sit here and make a couple tops right
and so I'm looking at is once the Market
opens is it going to shoot up here and
then reverse off of this level and is
that a move that I can profit from and
again waiting for that timing to show up
that's the most powerful thing and so
from there I go into a often a 5-minute
chart but also a 1 minute chart so if we
kind of again Zoom back to where the
Mark was open it kind of opens up here
you know again 7:30 my time is when it
opens up and then it kind of starts to
shoot higher and so even once it breaks
out of this Zone this is that support
level from that higher time frame once
we kind of get to there I'm going to go
through a kind of a four-step checklist
to see if it's a trade that I want to
jump in on that's what I kind of do
every day is I look for these levels I
look to see if it hits my four-step
checklist and then I also trying to look
for okay does it show up with that
timing is at 8:00 for me or 30 minutes
after after the market is it going to
set up this signal and potentially
reverse and so to show you what this is
kind of like in real time I want to walk
you through the recording of This trade
I took this morning so you can kind of
get a better feel of what it's like to
do this in real time and it's not just
talking about it hindsight and so my
step checklist is the first one is it
coming up to that level this is from a
15-minute chart it's just off of these
highs I'm just waiting for it to punch
up into this area right and I want to
see it start to slow down and so it's
okay if it breaks out of this level like
this because what often happens is I
like to call it a failed breakout you
know a lot of people like breakout
Traders they want to see something break
the previous high and then they're going
to bet that it's going to go up because
they think okay it's broken that
resistance level it's going to go up and
the reason why I kind of like to use
zones in my resistance and support
levels is because it's really rough on
where something is going to reverse you
don't exactly know where that's going to
happen and so I like to give it a grain
of salt of like hey this is the area I'm
kind of looking but it can you know what
it can come up here a little bit and
then reverse as well and so this is what
I look for a potential fail breakout and
so the next thing is is now this is
looking at a one minute chart that's
what I like to generally enter in on I
sometimes use a 5-minute chart and again
you can use this on a bigger time frame
chart if you want to but what I'm
looking at is you know here 730 where
the market open and it's kind of shot up
up here pretty quickly and I drew a
support trend line based off that
because I want to see where is the trend
line what is it doing if you're looking
for a reversal and betting that the
Market's going to go down here and
making money off of that you don't want
to go against the trend right you often
hear the trend is your friend and in
this case I don't want to go against
that either right and so I'm looking to
say okay well this uptrend right here I
think it's clearly broken once it's kind
of done this and so from that point okay
the Trends are broken what I want to see
now is a potential for it uh I like to
look for reversal patterns and a lot of
the time that is something like a double
top if this comes up here and then
starts to reverse I really like that as
a signal and the idea because that is
it's made an attempt to go higher again
and then it's it it's not able to break
this new high before getting rejection
and this is a really good Candlestick I
actually have a video where I talk all
about Candlestick patterns I highly
recommend checking it out it'll go more
in depth on why I really like this
pattern but the whole idea here is the
market tried to keep going higher and
then boom we have this massive big
rejection bar and now what I've recently
started doing too is well I want to see
how the second candle reacts and so to
show you what that means is basically
the market came down over those candles
pulled back up and then it's rejecting
and I like to put my order right below
that basically below this low saying
okay you know if it really is going to
break down there boom I want to get in
in because I think that's a really good
confirmation of essentially this double
top being confirmed as best as you can
confirm anything in trading and then
from there I enter in on a trade you can
see I put it in a stop loss a stop
market order technically and so it
jumped in me on on eight contracts and
then I put my stop- loss up here and so
I always like to put my stop loss above
a key swing I don't do it based on a
certain size I like to do it based on on
the price movement in the market because
again I'm getting into the trade because
of the candlesticks and a logical reason
and so I want to get out based on a
logical reason and The Logical reason
for me is hey if we come up here and
break this High I want to get out at
that point and so you can see I actually
moved my stop loss down here because I
saw the market make a little double
bottom here and it had a big pushup here
and quite honest this morning my overall
thought with the market and my intuition
was was kind of saying I think the
overall is bullish and so even though I
you know I'm betting that the Market's
going to go down I'm getting short based
on that I thought that we were more
likely to go up and so I still jumped in
on this trade because the signal was so
solid and again looking at that timing
it's 8:00 it's 30 minutes after the
Market opens that is my key timing of
when the market is going to potentially
reverse and so having all these signals
show up it was good enough to jump in
the trade I was still a little nervous
but in trading you have to jump through
that nervousness and then from there I
moved this down to essentially Break
Even after seeing this kind of pullback
happened and my thought was okay well
you know if it's going to come down here
and break and go up I want to get out
because I'm overall leading a little
bullish on the market but you know you
can see clearly it held and then from
there just to show you a couple targets
and how the market works is think about
it like this so we have you know in the
big picture I've reversed up here
betting lower right and so the first
couple targets would be okay the
Market's going to give this move back up
right here basically to where the market
opened or it could come all the way down
here and so those are a couple targets
you want to think about and even looking
on a one minute chart you can see here
here's where the market opened it had a
nice move up and we're going to look for
it to give that back up and I think
right about here is three times my risk
reward I like to go for a higher risk
reward ratio a positive one because
that's more more likely going to make
you profitable in the long run you know
I'm only right 50% of the time with
these but because I go for three times
my risk I can lose and win about the
same time but still make money in the
long run that's the whole goal with
trading is find something that's
repeatable like this at 8:00 a.m. and
then go for something that gives you a
positive risk World ratio it doesn't
have to be three times your risk you can
do two times if that makes you more
comfortable but that's how you want to
approach trading and then from there
just to kind of of Zoom this forward
because it took a little while to play
out but it also started to break lower
and so part of me thought about okay
maybe I should get down out at a limit
order here and I should kind of get out
when it you know made this kind of big
move lower and so totally getting out
down here at a limit order would have
been totally fine but I kind of put my
stoploss order here and then from there
it you know kind of had a bounce here
and knocked me out at about $600 and I
moved on with my day after trading for
only 60 minutes this morning I
discovered something recently about my
30 minute reversal timing in the markets
that instead allows you to look at a few
key factors and know when it's not going
to do that and you can actually take a
continuation trade and so this is
something that's repeatable every
morning of looking for the market to
either reverse at a key level or break
through a key level and you can take
trades on either direction and so
normally every morning I look for key
levels and look for things to reverse
but instead sometimes when if we just
zoom out here on a 5-minute chart of the
NASDAQ is when things are so bullish
it's more likely to continue breaking
through resistance levels and you don't
want to be counter turn trading at that
PL at that point you want to be trying
to buy the breakouts and get in on the
pushes higher and so to show you a real
trade of this normally I draw my levels
off of a 15-minute chart if we zoom out
you can see we are in a really strong
uptrend right now and so you know any
previous resistance level we've blown
through and even I can't even Zoom so
far back on a 15minute chart you have to
zoom all the way out on a daily chart to
see essentially this previous all-time
high actually on the NASDAQ of where
that level is and so where we could
potentially break out of and so from
there going into a 5-minute chart this
is kind of what I was looking at this
day is I was looking at okay we're
coming up into this level and then
zooming in on a one minute chart what
that looks like is you know again
looking for my 30 minute reversal timing
Market opens up at 7:30 we kind of
started to push higher and we come up
into about 8:00 we come up into this
resistance Zone and start to slow down
we kind of start to make a double top
here and it's not a crazy big double top
and so the reason why I didn't
technically take a short here because if
you look at this it kind of hits my
normal checklist we came up to a
resistance Zone we broke this trend line
and we've made kind of a double top and
a potential reversal bar right here as
well but the thing is with trading the
most important thing always is not these
little micro patterns that you look at
on a smaller time frame chart when
you're entering is it's the big picture
and the big picture is that this Market
is really bullish right now going back
to that daily chart is look at how this
box is huge and so you can see that the
day did close up pushing the highs of
this box but right now when it's opening
and we're looking for this reversal is
it's right here right it's right at
essentially the bottom of this box
looking at the 5 minute chart you can
see that kind of it moves up here and
we're starting to just have a a
consolidation a bull flag as you might
say and so that's why the big picture is
important and the reason why is because
that allows me to say hey I actually
don't want to bet short here I'm going
to hold off and save my money you know
maybe I could be wrong and it could
reverse here and I'll miss out on a nice
swing but you have to go with your read
otherwise you're just kind of blindly
following a plan and rules and you have
to go with the overall big picture
that's the most important part that's
the hard part about trading is it is a
little subjective but going into this
that's what you have to kind of do
sometimes and so you know the NASDAQ
just kind of was chopping here right and
so when it gets into that point A lot of
times what I want to see is a big
bearish Candlestick here and what that
does is when the Market's chopping so
much and just a big candle out of
nowhere happens a lot of people get fomo
they'll jump in and and it'll bait them
and so what I like to see is it kind of
start to quickly reverse that and so
when that happens and it aligns up with
your overall idea that we're going to
actually push higher that that is a very
good signal to I think jump in long and
so I actually jumped in after that
signal I actually waited for one more
little pullback here is it pushed higher
baited people essentially it it there's
a tiny little box right here right and
it broke the lows essentially you know
breakout Traders and previous old me
that maybe wouldn't have seen these
signals when I was kind of new to
reversing I would have got in short here
because this looks like a nice bare
breakout right but again using that
overall picture is I actually think this
is going to go up and so we then got a
couple of of candles here where it kind
of just sits here and so going into the
recording of This in real time again to
show you is that's where I got long as I
jumped in right after basically this
kind of pullback here and then I put my
stop loss below this low and I bet that
the market was going to go higher this
is nerve-wracking for me it's kind of
not the norm versus betting that the
Mark's going to go down but when all
those things are aligning and you have
this kind of fake lower and this fake
lower and you have that bigger picture
Trend that's really strong is that's
where I like to jump in you know you can
take that 30 minute timing and say okay
well it's not working today because of
few factors and I can profit off of that
in a different way and so once it kind
of breaks out up here I moved my stop
loss to break even because you know if
this just kind of pukes back down right
here the Market's just in a really
choppy State and you just want to get
out of that point point the idea is that
it's going to break out here and you're
going to find some momentum and you're
going to be able to capture a profitable
trade and so from here once we start to
break out you can see it's you know I'm
I'm making really good money off this
trade and this move is happening really
nicely and you know just One Direction
and so when the market moves up so
quickly like that I like to Trail up my
stop loss and get out you know when it
starts to turn quickly because I want to
maximize my profits and so I jump out on
you know 2/3 3/4 of my trade right there
and then what I do is I allow kind of I
leave a little bit on with the idea that
what this does is when you're trading
you're going to have all these emotions
in your mind of well what if it just
keeps going higher and you know I closed
out all of my trades and I I missed out
right or what if this is it and I should
have got out here and it just reverses
and so I find scaling out a certain
amount over time allows me to mentally
deal with that I can get out you know
2/3 3/4 of my trade whatever makes sense
at you know two or three times I risk or
when kind of you know a big tight move
up like this has broken clearly right
here and then I can slowly manage the
rest of the trade because it'll allow me
to you know get a little bit more if
there is a little bit more in the trade
you know sometimes the market can go 5
10x my trades doesn't happen very often
but when it does I like to be on that
ride and so from here you know the
market just kind of moves up pretty
quick and and I kind of try and Trail up
this a little bit more and get out and I
think you know that trade closed up
probably $900 or something and it was a
great trade and so the same thing
happened where you know I was done by
9:00 which was a little longer but an
hour and a half 90 minutes and I can
move on with the day and so if you want
to learn more about this strategy check
out this playlist right here it'll talk
you through everything more about and
managing these trades finding the key
support and resistance levels and also
talking about those Candlestick patterns
that are so important to finally
entering in on the trade